cause you did it
what the hell
cactus
holy [ __ ] where did that come from oh
he's up there
there's a zombie and he's protected from
the
oh oh dude
i backed in the cactus and i thought it
was you that hit me i was like what the
hell
yeah it was me can you please hurry up
and stop doing your [ __ ] okay we can
go now look at this on me
collette
i'm going to make a bowl later i got
some feather i think
yeah i got some arrows
hide this zombie
uh come here
how are you doing don't disturb him
please kill him
seriously yeah
why the [ __ ] he was awesome he was keep
watching over us
he was stuck okay i'm gonna have my
sword as well hey down here
let's check this out
maybe we can find some steel or whatever
let's take this first oh yeah
nice man
uh we should go to first
oh god there's a zombie
kill it
where it's like right in front of me
uh who's on fire now [ __ ]
all right oh you want to head down here
i'm going in here oh yeah let's go to
here first
stupid cow elephant
out of the cow
there's nothing in here just a
pretty oh there's grip
that scared the [ __ ] out of me
wow let's go in here there's some cold
air i might as well oh there's some
water
because i need to make more torches
look at this water
isn't this nice where are you
where do you go oh there you are
ah
that's pretty neat
it's like on the same water level
i keep hearing the elephant
it sounds like one it's a cow
i thought it was a pig
okay let's get out of there yeah it's
nice nice hot lagoon or whatever oh
feather you dropped the feather
yeah
i was like i'm gonna give you the [ __ ]
oh you're so nice
dude wait for me [ __ ]
you should not you know
you should not wait for me [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i got very little health now
okay let's go back to bed no no we're
gonna explore
no i got i got really loud i'm gonna go
in here because you're such a goddamn
[ __ ] i gotta kill some cows
it's a [ __ ] elephant oh there was
nothing in here
oh that's good we got that cleared out
oh hide that piggy get up
thanks for your meets
how long have we been recording
uh i i
i didn't take any timer
oh
maybe we should end now and then next
time we say
like let's keep going this is fun
no i meant we can keep going but we can
end this part
yeah
okay see you guys in part two
welcome back no that wasn't obnoxious
welcome back to broad i don't know which
part this is
this is a part
maybe it is inaudible
maybe it's a military penis
we need more
what the [ __ ] you doing making some
stuff around my stripper pole you got a
problem with that [ __ ]
yes
i really need steel i want to make a
bucket
why
because i [ __ ] said so
but why
well the turtle band
are you even doing
is it stairs yeah it is yay
when we tried to do this in multiplayer
and the stairs was called buggy
that was so annoying
i'm glad he fixed it i'm gonna find some
steel [ __ ]
you can go explore i'm gonna
be ahead and be boring and mine
[Music]
but but
i'm gonna kill some cats
[ __ ] you kale no it's
pigs my bad
of course
how can you be sucked up
[ __ ] cow
[ __ ] your cow can you eat the stuff the
cow drop
no it's you can make armor i thought you
could make hamburgers
no
come here sheep
come and give me a hug go get some
oh there's a lot of pumpkins on top of
that
yeah why don't you climb up but together
but i only have one life i'm pretty sure
i'm gonna die
okay i'm coming
wait no no no i can do it but it's like
i need to be careful
you can come if you want to though no
how can it happen to me i made my
mistakes got nowhere i'm the king of the
world
i'm the king of the world
awesome
oh there's even more pumpkins over there
i want to catch them all
pumpkins
pokemon
you started it no
was the joke your friend told me earlier
uh what pokemons are like stds oh yeah
you're not cool until you catch them all
i'm pretty sure i should head back
because i have very little health
and very poor sense of direction i will
ruffle if you die oh they're already
spawned
[ __ ] round batch one there's no way i
can make it
lol the ship is kissing the cactus and
now he does
wait how the [ __ ] am i supposed to get
down
i don't even remember where i came from
i can't see it get away creeper
where the [ __ ] are you
[ __ ]
i'm going to try it to find you
oh god there's a creeper
i'm
i i don't know how to explain
don't jump down there
i see you all right did you see me uh
let's see i'm hopping on the wide
humping
jumping just see me no
i'm here oh now see you
i'm here
yeah i know that can you teleport me
is that work
no you should make a base up there and
then when it's day you should go down
no it didn't work
i should make a base wow
yeah so you don't could make some bacon
though
yeah but you need a phone up here
luckily
all right a lot of torches and i can't
well let's get it after me
get some code when you're back
dude it's gonna take a while
good look at mine alone uh
what hello don't you love me
nope okay uh i think i'm gonna
i wanna head over there because it's a
bunch of pumpkins over there and i like
pumpkins
i like pumpkin pie you love them don't
you
yes i don't know
what is this
it's your face
oh really
yeah
um i want a better minding
pickaxe i want a diamond pickaxe
oh i felt so cold
goddammit can it be day already it's
take forever
where should i
see here
looks like a sand castle
there and then
there
dude why do you remove the torch how am
i supposed to find back here
oh wait i can't go out and place it oh
it's all right it's still like
ah this is getting boring i'm gonna move
just
if you die can i have your stuff
sure man
oh what if i could jump in the water
that would be awesome
damn this is a bold move
360.
[Laughter]
ah